jordan vous puisque vous avez pensez
vous de la campagne
marine a commencé très tôt sa compagne
parce que il y avait beaucoup de sujets
abordés et qu'on partait à cette
élection pour pour la gagner c'est ce
qu'on compte faire dimanche donc on a
commencé effectivement très tôt à faire
beaucoup de réunions publiques à aller
sur le terrain est vraiment une campagne
loin des grandes villes dans les
campagnes aux cartes qu'on a très
longtemps appelée la française oubliez
moi ce qui m'a beaucoup gêné c'est en
fait le refus d' emmanuel macron
quasiment de faire campagne avec comme
la volonté d'enjamber l'élection dire
qu'il n'a pas voulu débattre avant le
premier tour pas de débat c'est à dire
que lui jupiter est là haut ils
regardent le peuple s'affronter en bas
puis prendra éventuellement le survivant
il prendra le gagnant pour le second
tour ça ça va beaucoup gêner le coc vide
et l'ukraine ont quand même été c'est
des éléments très importants mais un peu
une excuse parce que le coc vide au mois
de octobre novembre décembre n'y a pas
de vivre ça s'empêche pas de débattre
d'autres sujets et l'ukraine est venue
très très tard dans la campagne
présidentielle dont ukraine ou pas
ukraine en fait on savait qu emmanuel
macron aller attend le dernier moment
pour se déclarer et en fait se déclarer
le plus tard possible d'abord je trouve
que c'est un manque de respect pour les
français pour la démocratie et surtout
pour les autres candidats qui sont au
même niveau qu emmanuel macron il est
peut être président mais quand il se
représente il est candidat et puis
surtout c'est l'euro en fait ça permet
d'éviter de parler du bilan ça permet
d'éviter de parler de des gilets jaunes
la mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites du climat de la sécurité du
pouvoir d'achat ça permet en fait mieux
fuir tous les ans par lille avait de
quoi les aider l'armée avant le premier
tour mais jugeant la demande est là vous
en parler pourquoi vous n y en a pas
parlé pendant des affaires le débat
n'a pas parlé parce que en fait
jacques marie le panel a fait un choix
qui était celui de parler d'elle et de
son projet alors oui c'est pas un match
de boxe ça c'est vrai c'est pas un match
de boxe elle n'est pas allée critique
emmanuel macron léger ça les français je
pense le connaissent mais elle avait
vraiment fait ce choix c'est une
stratégie qu'on assume c'était de dire
je veux que dans les 2 heures 40 qui me
sont un parti avec le nombre de sujets
que les français puissent se dire à la
fin du débat voilà ce qu'elle va faire
pour la france et voilà les mesures
qu'elle va mettre en place c'est un
choix alors certes c'est peut-être pas
sensationnel peut-être que vous auriez
aimé un peu plus de combat etc moi je
trouve que c'était un débat extrêmement
clair on voit les deux projets de
société et on peut dire à la fin du
débat voilà ce que l'un ou l'autre va
faire pour le payer pour les frontières
et les meetings alors les meetings pour
pour parler je te demande du fonds du
programme et là le débat permettait
justement
vous permettez généralement dans les
meetings vous parlez à vos ministres
qu'à vous parlez plus du bilan et à la
télé vous avez jonas de gens qui ne
voient pas pour vous donc faut aller les
combishorts gens regardez là juste il ya
eu les autres émissions aussi et les
émissions de france 2 il ya eu face à
bakka khel a fait mais qu'il n'a pas
voulu faire oui voilà mais c'est vrai
que via lui il ya eu il ya eu quand même
des rendez vous elle a pu exposer quand
même son son débat là c'est vrai que sur
le sur le débat de l'entre-deux tours on
s'est dit c'est vrai qu'on a eu on n'a
pas posé des questions sur sur les
gilets jaunes bien sûr le sur l'ailé les
masses auriez dû faire le débat alors
oui j'aurais dû à un non mais non mais
non nécessairement pas été imposée par
les candidats si mais en fait je
t'attends dans le cadre par les médecins
qui avaient beaucoup de thèmes et peu de
temps c'est servette quand vous allez 10
minutes sur le sahara d'achat vous
n'avez pas le temps qu'on vous dit voilà
on dit mais voilà ce que je vais faire
voilà ce qu emmanuel macron bien faire
et ensuite les français choisissent mais
après le bilan je pense que les français
ressentent les français ressentent
qu'ils arrivent plus aujourd'hui à
boucler leurs factures ils ressentent
connu une situation d'insécurité qui est
partout dans le pays y voit bien que les
femmes aujourd'hui bah quand elles
sortent elles sont contraintes de se
retourner pour voir si elles ne sont pas
suivies parce qu'il ya une insécurité
qui est qui qui touche aujourd'hui
toutes les villes de france que les gens
de plus en plus de mal aujourd'hui dans
certains territoires à trouver un
médecin donc en fait le bilan des
manuels macro ils le vivent au quotidien
la politique de mâcon sur les 60 % taxe
sur les carburants ils le vivent au
quotidien donc nous on vient leur dire
voilà ce qu'on va faire à la place voilà
ce qu'on va faire concrètement pour
répondre à vos attentes et c'est la
stratégie qu'on a qu'on est ici pendant
le débat
on